they're investigating elon musk now yes
they're going after him because he
allegedly didn't hire enough non-us
citizens
i think that's the story yeah lydia can
you look that up
uh elon musk investigated for hiring
non-us
citizens which is a little bit
mind-boggling but i think in the justice
department you have a man
very thing that you need to hire non-us
citizens either way
the issue is elon musk may be i think
his second richest guy on the planet
they will come after him that's the art
i he's not in the club
but the reality is the club has fallen
apart yeah and i think it says it in the
second byline there
uh the doj's immigrant and employee
rights section said it received a
complaint
of employment discrimination from a
non-us citizen in may
and said spacex refused to comply with a
subpoena for relevant documents related
to hiring my mind is blown
yeah well there you go i know that he's
probably here about who he hires
the u.s department of justice
investigating spacex over whether the
company discriminates against non-us
citizens in its hiring
according to court documents filed on
thursday that's insane
wow what that is crazy i remember
reading that a couple days ago and
reporting on my channel i'm like wait
wait wait wait they're going after him
for
that you can't discriminate again that
listen we're america we're not
look look you know they don't have
social security numbers no no no
isn't it isn't it painfully obvious
right now what's happening the club
let's okay so we talked about something
a while ago about i think this last week
i was talking about hillary clinton
losing
and i was like i always thought the game
was rigged you know i was just like
what's the point of voting and then
donald trump won and i was like huh
i guess you really can get your
candidate to win that restored my faith
in the system
all right but then i wondered how is it
that he won like
certainly the establishment elites who
manipulate media
and manipulate the markets could have
wrangled up enough effort to
to win and i'm not talking about fraud
or cheating i'm talking about
you know mail-in voting systems about
changing laws about
you know um running stories like what
they're doing right now about silver
just blatantly just wrong stories over
manipulation
and it's because they didn't they
underestimated the internet and the meme
magic
no joke trump was memed into the
president they overestimated hillary
clinton
definitely a little bit yeah yep and so
then i started to think maybe the
the establishment elites who normally
have a have an airtight control over the
media and the narrative and the system
are slipping they're losing their grip
now you look at what's going on with
gamestop the gamestop stocks
and it's like they're losing their grip
the hedge funds are
are bleeding out cash now you look at
how the media responded
with this what looks to be a coordinated
smear campaign to trick regular
americans
into buying up this slv losing money
but we can see right through it now it's
almost like you know the wizard of oz
and they pulled the curtain back and we
can see the man behind the curtain
he's still going just close my eyes and
they won't see me right
when i was on the show one of the first
times you were like what do we do what's
the solution i'm like memes and you're
like what do you mean means what are you
talking about
and i'm like dude you don't get it man
there's a whole culture that even
popeyes is picking up on
and the memes are literally the ones
that are waking people up and are more
effective
than a lot of the mainstream media
propaganda the cathedral is terrified of
memes i think ever since trump was
elected i think watching this gamestop
stuff is really making it worse yeah
there's a lot of even uh
documents that are uncovered and i have
to refresh myself and i don't want to
speak out of hand here
and i and i think that we're referring
to your water to
to special operations talking about meme
warfare
that was released by edward snowden i
have to double check but
there's this is something that of course
government agencies see as a massive
threat
and i i think that i think the memes i
mean they're they're viral right now
i'm tweeting and i'm instagramming a
whole bunch of them all the time because
just in that one simple image in that
simple representation you're able to get
across
ideas so much more effectively than any
video than any photo than any article
than any other kind of media form
and it's really its own form and and the
shares and the clicks and the way that
this spreads
is just exactly how this whole reddit
movement started
and exactly how it it has a momentum and
has an energy
and and when you look at even you know
the epstein situation no one even knew
about
it until the memes started coming out
and that hashtag started coming out
so so this is key and essential and and
looking at the memes now
things are looking in favor of the
rhetoric there's something really
interesting jon stewart
i guess joined twitter recently yeah and
he tweeted
cheering on the the redditors he he
joined twitter did i say read it he
joined twitter and started cheering
you said twitter okay he started now
he's cheering on the redditors and game
style saying good kick it to wall street
you know take them for what they're
worth
jimmy kimmel so i couldn't find this
tweet i don't know if jimmy kimmel
deleted it but a bunch of people were
sharing it yeah i saw it
apparently he said real donald trump is
this you or something like that
that you do and he is obsessed well no
no someone made a really good point
jon stewart is an old school liberal who
has been
out of the game for several years he's
probably been minding his own business
for the most part
not realizing the sh the realignment
that's occurred jimmy kimmel is
realignment left
so he's a mock he's mocking uh jon
stewart
jon stewart comes out and says the right
thing is a leftist and he gets he gets
accused of being trump
and you look at what cnn said trumpism
explains
what's going on with with cnn jimmy
kimmel has has lost
i mean this is maybe i'm just preaching
to the choir this is obvious but he is
completely
gone well if you if you look at that i
mean he's not i was going to say
something kind of offensive you know
that term off the native american
but yeah the whole phrase off the
reservation is a very
racist phrase i've come to learn but i
don't know it just means something about
a native american leaving
and then it's like that makes them crazy
or something like that i don't know
well also back to jimmy kimmel here i
mean when you look at him
you look at his eyes he looks beaten wow
he looks defeated he looks like
i i you know i don't want to kind of
expound on here but but
he looks like he's not there he looks
like he's just absolutely miserable
doing his job
yes look look when i see a lot of these
people in media colbert and kimmel and
these like late night hosts
there's no passion they don't care it's
like
dude give me the script and i'll read it
okay so uh russian bots are buying stock
and uh what's that line redditor what is
what
that is that's all they're bad guys and
i would advise everyone to go watch this
kimmel talk
it's 30 seconds long and he mentions
that the redditors might be russian
assets
russian bots did he write that or did
his writers write that and hand it to
him and he just went with it
it's the cathedral man it's disgusting
what does russia have
anything to do with these russian people
with these russian people
it starts with an army well bloomberg
even went on to describe
people a part of this larger movement as
insurrectionist
so did the former sec chairman uh
so we have to understand this is
aggressive language that we're seeing
towards poor people playing the market
and outsmarting the people who used to
play the market the hedge funds this
reminds me of
occupy wall street because at occupy
wall street the banks began
to rupture you could see their terror um
the whole industry was like you know
what the jig is up it's
we're done for let's save as many of our
necks as we can because they're working
it's over just really quick i want to
make a point here what made occupy wall
street prominent because it was ignored
for a very long time was a
disproportionate
response by the state they were
extremely aggressive and they hit
back very hard and there was one pepper
spray incident that really went viral
that started everything tony bologna
tony baloney
exactly and it was literally
overreaction by the state we're seeing
another overreaction by the authorities
by the establishment right now as we're
speaking with this absurdity
that some people are calling news let me
let me tell you
luke democracy dies in darkness did you
know this ah i heard
the washington post which is the bezos
times
in their in their op-ed about the hedge
funds being the good guys
let me read a passage for you they said
this time is different
the game stop speculators are not merely
in a frenzy about one stock
their goal is to destroy the traders who
link stock prices to
fair value to suggest a political
analogy
they are not just blindly devoted to
their candidate they deny the legitimacy
of the opposition party
they are not just acting within the
system they want to
overthrow the system it says though just
imagine
a rabble gripped by conspiracy theories
were to attack the rules of democracy
itself
the name gamestop is apt do you know
what that passage is saying
they're saying the redditors are the
same thing as trump supporters
and the action they're taking is the
same as the insurrection is is the
they're calling it you know essentially
the insurrection attacking democracy
itself the storming of the campaign
wrote that by the way
uh he oh you're like this luke this is
sebastian
maliby he's the paul a volcker senior
fellow for international economics the
council on foreign relations ah
okay makes perfect sense yes i know this
you know we have barely they kicked me
out of there permanently and banned me
you were walking around
yes i had a very interesting
conversation with mr paul volcker you
could look it up on we are change
he was actually very nice but he was
lost so i was literally telling him
where to go into a secret vip room that
he accidentally took me into
whoopsie because security goes like oh
he's clearly with him and then that's
when he brought me to ben bernanke
another individual who by the way
is also a senior advisor at citadel
which people should know
and is also the former chairman of the
u.s federal reserve and citadel owns
stock the silver stock that's you said
that's like 50 of their they own
i guess they own slv look i'm i'm just
basically going off of what wall street
bets has been saying about what's going
on so you went to the cfr i kind of want
to
touch on this oh yeah a number of times
where they had press events and
and it was actually this is a wild
story too it was eric schmidt's
girlfriend
who kicked me out of the cfr permanently
because i was always coming in there and
then they kicked me out and they denied
me press credentials so i had an alias
that i went under i got in there again
then they kicked me out then i had a
third alias
then say your alias i don't i don't want
to say i don't think
well one of them i'll release one of
them one of them is public and
his name was bill yes and last name de
berg
so when you read that together oh i see
it makes a statement about
another they didn't notice they didn't
notice they didn't know they're like oh
you've got mr bill here let them in
because i did the accreditation i had
credentials they let me into the council
on foreign relations and they had press
conferences and i stood up
asked my question like everyone else but
the difference was i wasn't
kissing but i wasn't throwing softballs
i went right for the gullet verbally
with hardcore legitimate reasonable
questions
that should have been asked about
corruption and all these horrible things
that these people do in secret
that was finally exposed with this
questioning they hated it kicked me out
three times
and the fourth time eric schmidt's
girlfriend because i looked who this who
this was gave me a call personally she's
like luke we know who you are
just stop it you're banned you're not
coming in
we're doing this because you're going to
be arrested if you step foot into the
cfr i don't care how many aliases i
don't care how many disguises you have
you're not coming in
and i'm like ladies ladies and gentlemen
i waited outside by the way
who's eric schmidt again eric schmidt is
the former chairman of alphabet the
former head of
google who also is working with the
government especially the pentagon on
their technological advancements
in the military now that you've
mentioned eric schmidt is formerly the
head of
google if you were wondering why he
might get banned in the future
because this guy's got us he's sitting
right here well my channel was kicked
out of the partner program
i think very unfairly i mean if i mean
did you ever find out why no oh come on
no he
he he you ambushed eric schmidt i didn't
ambush i asked him a question
ambush journalism is just a reference to
you seeing him walking and going up and
asking him questions
i'm not saying it directly i politely
asked him about financing and
fundraising a lot of the tink thinks
that were thanks sorry good enough you
know what i'm saying here
think tanks think tanks that were
organizing the term fake news
because the term fake news kind of came
out of nowhere nowhere and it was
galvanized
as a way pushed by hillary clinton to go
against donald trump to go against
independent media
and it all started according to a lot of
investigative journalism from a lot of
the groups that were financed directly
by him and google
so i went up to him and i was like hey
eric schmidt let's talk about you
working with hillary clinton on her
campaign let's talk about you donating
to her and you helping her create some
of the biggest buzzwords that the media
is using right now and weaponizing right
now
to destroy free speech and then he
looked you in the eyes and listen here's
your little piss ant
he was like this is effing absurd uh
you're effing crazy i'm like sir please
stop cursing you're gonna get my youtube
video demonetized
and obviously i knew that you know but
that's not the first time we got him uh
we also got him at another bilderberg in
switzerland this is
all of course as he's going to the
bilderberg group meeting which the
mainstream media by and large
chooses not to report on even though
it's 150 of the most influential people
come together
in secret let's let's we we gotta hit
that point because
how do these all factor and there's
bilderberg davos and the council on
foreign relations there's also the
trilateral commission and there's groups
within groups within groups and
affiliations within all these different
groups and i could talk about this for
hours but
one last thing before we segue i kind of
really wanted to bring up some of the
amazing positive stories we should focus
on some of those here
and those are of individuals who enrich
themselves through this whole gamestop
saga
and they're doing incredible things the
new york post has an article right now
that is titled
college student donates game stop gains
to buy video games for sick
kids and there's a large number of these
individuals actually going out of their
way
taking profit and doing really like
amazing
things that are act that are helping
people you look at the hedge fund that's
that money
yeah that's hedge fund money yeah
exactly that what do hedge funds do
the the the ceo of of malvin capital
is still moving forward with literally
destroying and bulldozing a house
next to his so he could build a tennis
court that's what
melvin capital is this kid he's making
sure sick kids get video games he's
making sure
people get helped in their communities
and you see tons of these stories there
was another post on reddit
that said this is for my father that was
absolutely a tear-jerker that that
talked about a lot of the bigger things
about a lot of the bigger reasons a lot
of the
motive behind this which is absolutely
important to know the story was that his
dad's
construction company i believe
construction was destroyed
by the housing market crisis caused by
these big banks
and that since that needs to become like
basically a destitute alcoholic who's
lost the will to live
yes and so he's like this is for you dad
this is this is you know
the the the son has come back for
vengeance against those but this is
important a lot of these reddit kids
saw their families devastated especially
in 2008 they were kicked out of their
homes in the in the housing market
crisis
last year they had their private
businesses enterprises shut down by the
lockdowns and here they are
saying we're going to come together and
we're going to play by the rules and
we're going to work the market towards
the benefit of
everyone we're gonna literally be robin
hood
in the modern day and age and what
happens the system conspires
colludes against them calls them
insurrectionists calls them
losers says they're connected to russia
says that they're going to be cutting
themselves and
and and harming themselves are you
kidding me because they made a little
bit of money that they're actually
spreading around
to the economy that is sick and
disgusting bastardization of news
and people's responsibility if you're a
journalist right now and you're not
reporting on this fairly and honestly
you are not a journalist you're a
propaganda mouthpiece for the
establishment elite and you have no soul
within yourself and i am sick of these
people they know it yeah and they don't
care
like when i saw that bloomberg that clip
from wall street about
about the bloomberg saying redditors
lose interest i'm like what are you
talking about it's the number one post
right now on reddit telling people to
buy more stock
one dude just announced who's putting a
million dollars into gamestop
a million bucks right now is not going
down they are lying
these are not journalists they know
they're propagandists for the state
and they know what they're doing for the
longest time i've given many of them
the benefit of the doubt but each and
every one of these was writing an
article saying buy silver
redditors want you to buy silver they
know they are lying
or they're just useful idiots who are
too stupid to do their job
one thing's for sure they're not
journalists thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check
us out when we go live don't forget to
subscribe hit the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time